hey guys I wanted to create a important
video on the seven surprising things
that can kick you out of ketosis now you
may know the typical things like sugar
you know and refined carbohydrates but
these are things that you may not know
that are important number one stress can
kick you out of ketosis because stress
activates a hormone called cortisol
cortisol is the main adrenal hormone
that adapts the body to stress so any
type of stress shock to the system even
a surgery trauma allergies even the loss
of a loved one can activate stress
stress on your job relationship stress
boom that can actually knock you out of
ketosis I bet you didn't know that one
next next one is excessive caffeine now
one cup of coffee is not going to do
anything but if you're doing coffee all
day long or tea all day long with
caffeine too much of that connective
eight adrenaline which can then activate
insulin alright
bone broth in large quantities now a
little bit of bone broth is not going to
be an issue but we're talking to protein
protein will activate it it can bump you
out I'm not too concerned about bone
broth even when you're fasting it may
knock you out a little bit but it's a
very very small amount so I'm not too
concerned about that whey protein is one
of the top proteins because it's low fat
and high protein that will stimulate
insulin and knock you out of ketosis and
then we have l-glutamine now that people
take that for your digestive system
leaky gut irritable bowel syndrome it's
a it's a protein and it can knock you
out of ketosis now I'm not concerned
about you taking that because it really
helps you in certain ways it's not going
to put weight on but the only reason I
bring it up is because as you tense
yourself and all of a sudden you get
knocks you out don't be concerned that's
what's doing it it's going to be a
temporary thing but it will knock you
out okay and then we have MSG monosodium
glutamate another name for that is
modified food starch it's in so many
foods and it's easy to avoid if you're
shopping but it's very hard to avoid if
you're going out to restaurants because
they have it in the sauces they have it
in the dressings they have it in the
in some of the flavor enhancers on
Peruvian chicken loaded with MSG so
they've any food that just tastes too
good typically has msg on it especially
if it's the fast-food restaurant next
one
artificial sweeteners aspartame Splenda
that has actual dextran and it also has
multi dextran that will not give out and
Sakhalin these are artificial sweeteners
that can raise insulin so another
interesting hidden thing and then excess
that protein will do it to let's say you
have this big steak and that's why the
Atkins diet which is high in protein
they're allowing too much protein that
can spike insulin and knock you out of
ketosis so ideal sweet spot for most
people between three to six ounces per
meal all right
now if you're actually doing two meals a
day or one meal a day and you're trying
to do them at fasting where you're just
condensing that to from three to two to
one and you keeping your calories higher
maybe you can get a get away with like
eight ounces of protein you know but
typically it's three to six now if you
just as a side note if you combine sugar
with protein you will majorly spike
influence so that's even worse than
excessive protein next one is to mini
keto desserts now let me just explain
this I always recommend taking like one
maybe two but not a whole bunch so if
you cannot just have one then don't make
them because you're in the keto desserts
you're going to add mannitol or multi
tall or xylitol or wheat or tall some of
these sugar alcohols now retort roll has
a Glee glycemic index of zero stevia has
a glycemic index of zero donnatal has a
little higher glycemic index mannitol
and multiple has even higher glycemic
index now it's a lot less than sugar but
it still can affect insulin a little bit
I personally consume xylitol in very
small amounts but if I put it in the
keto desert I'm not going to do massive
quantities of these keitel
which are little cookies that can really
knock you out of ketosis so again just
because it says it's keto friendly
doesn't always mean it's cute a friendly
in large quantities okay cough syrup has
hidden sugar as well alcohol beer juice
those are all the kind of the known
things that these are the things that
you may not be aware of so if you can
think of anything else that could knock
you out put it down below I want to I
want to know what you think thanks for
watching hey guys I have a quick survey
question what is your biggest health
challenge right now something that is
just bugging you or stopping you from
achieving your goal just click the link
below let me know because I want to
create a video on that topic